wir würden heute beim kleinen 100
staaten wird machen wir eine kleine
pflege mit land berlin erstmal genau
dafür den blutzucker messen und
entsprechend das insulin spritzen und
dann nochmal die medikamente
kontrollieren und dem verabreichen
genauer als nächstes wollen wir das in
den nächsten patienten gehen die hat
eine infizierte bisswunde genau dies vom
rund gewissen wurden die wunderschön
verziert ist soweit vom strom solche
worden und soll jetzt durch den
pflegedienst quasi durch uns versorgt
werden ist er dann abgeheilt ist genau
richtig wir würden am anfang
gucken dass wir das über buch lesen was
die kollegen eingetragen haben gibt es
irgendwelche informationen hat jemand
ein arzttermin oder irgendwas genau dann
wird wie schlüssel nehmen damit wäre
dann auch in die wohnung kommen dann
wäre ich soweit bereit hast du noch
fragen
bis jetzt aber wir würden uns jetzt die
zwei schlüssel von patienten jetzt erst
mal mitnehmen
das wäre einmal den herum ich habe das
andere patienten noch das sind die zwei
schlüssel haben wir brauchen
[Musik]